hello everyone my air-conditioning is
still malfunctioning but your vast
knowledge is not going to increase on
its own so we better just check out this
very nice game a lot we have suggested
it already even though it was played
only yesterday see on the pony versus
Livio detron is mississippiana
an easy piano is a romanian chess
grandmaster as of 2014 he is a German
Grand Master who I think around 2005 was
rated amongst the top 15 players in the
world so it's really amazing that games
such as this one was played against to
such a very strong players and I would
just like to thank everyone who was able
to make it yesterday to my Instagram
chess quiz and the special
congratulations to everyone who got all
of the 15 questions correct so so thank
you all for coming
now getting back to this game like i
said it's round six of the Dortmund
chess meet up the annual Dortmund just
meet up and it's really just insane so
let's just dive straight into it also
there on the left you can see update of
a matter of chess clock so all of your
all of your suggestions were input in
Hindi a lot of chess clock even made all
the updates and it was released I
believe two days ago so make sure to
update your chess [ __ ] but it's still
not you know the full version being
released we still have a few things to
check up and then I will inform you but
if you want you're welcome to updated
now so getting back to the game Netta
opens with E 4 with E 5 Knight to f3 and
the Knight to f6 the better of defense
is on the board we have Knight captures
on e5 d6 all standard stuff and now
Knight captures on e4 and not nice to
see 3 this is my favorite line against
the Petrov Knight captures D captures
Bishop to e7 and now Bishop to e3 White
says maybe he's gonna go Queen d2 maybe
Castle queenside we have king-size
Castle by black and now Queen to d2 so
the main line here is nice to d7 just
transferring this Knight over to f6 from
f6 he will do a very nice job of
protecting the black King as white might
have some idea so bringing the Bishop to
d3 this Bishop to d4 maybe you know
lining up the bishop pair with it with
the black King but here in this upon who
plays Queen to d8 it's a very rare
I don't think it was played all that
many times especially not in high-level
chess the idea is to bring the Queen
over to a4 which is a really aggressive
idea especially if white castles King
side sorry Queen side and here are a few
moves were attempted Bishop to e2 was an
idea Bishop to d3 was an idea also
queenside castle was an idea but here
nipple goes for h4 and believe it or not
already in move nine we have a
completely new game this move was never
played in this position Sony Sipan who
continues Queen to a4 now of course you
will not be able to Castle queenside if
it has of Queen said just win captures
on a2 and white will not be very happy
about this sort never continues with h5
so you know just ignoring black's
previous move and h6 Nissa peon of
course does not want an effort to push
h6 with Bishop to d3 now developing the
bishop may be saying that he's ready to
Castle King side and now rook to e8
always useful move as Nepos King is
still in the center of the board and
it's not all that easy we already said
that you can't Castle queenside and if
you cancel Kings side for example King
side Castle didn't get Queen to g4 no
longer do you have a look on h1 to guard
your h5 point you can't really guard it
whatever you play next move black will
just capture here and you don't really
have anything to show for this so here
nipple plays King to f1 it's sort of
like sort of like castling and the King
is very safe there but you still keep
your rook guarding the h5 pawn and also
perhaps if you know something happens in
the position maybe you can get this very
nice roof lift in and introduce this
rope into the attack
so here Bishop the f8 and now opening up
the e-file to the rook and also the
bishop here will be very useful in
defending the Kings side so what can you
do here here never played Knights to d4
an excellent move by white would have
been looked to h4
because now the Queen is under attack
and if you and you have to decide where
you want to go Queen to c6 is possible
but the Queen is not all that useful on
c6 also if if Queen to c6 you just will
have problems developing your Queen side
night you can develop it the b7 but if
you develop it to d7
then the rook can come to h3 and it's
the same if the Queen retreats all the
way to these 7
now you can return to h3 with the rook
and then you can play rook to g3 and use
the rook for attack
so rook to h4 was a very interesting
idea here but okay neppo has a different
idea he plays Knight to d4 now
controlling the f5 squared the knife can
also now join the attack and here we
have Queen to d7 keeping an eye on the
on the f5 Square and also battling Queen
to d7 now you're not really now you can
develop the knight to c6 that's true but
you also allow this very nice rock lift
so you know a nice rook lift incoming by
nipple Luke to h3 the idea is of course
work to g3 since the Queen is not
blocking the bishop and here we have
Knight to c6 if you try something like
Bishop to f5 instead of rook to h3
doesn't really do anything
black will just move the Queen and then
you can trade on see it but black the
bishop is doing really nothing so
there's no point in something like this
if you were wondering maybe about that
so nice the c6 rook the g3 and here how
do you defend there's already a threat a
bishop characters on h6 is a threat
because there's a pin on the G file but
the best course of action for black
would have been Queen to e7 just giving
up the h6 pawn and here indeed if you
capture it a bunch of captures then you
get a Knight captures and before and
after C captures Queen to h4 as the
route controls the e-file now you're
threatening Queen to h1 mate so here
you'd have to play game did you want to
prevent mate but now Queen captures on
h5 and you know black black plays on
everything continues the mushroom guards
the g7 score so no threats are possible
there but an AC pan who played King to
h8 here he decided he doesn't want his
King on the G file so this is no longer
a threat as the bishop also controls the
h6 square so nipple says okay Knight
captures on c6 I have to get rid of your
control over the d4 square so I can get
my Bishop over to d4
we have but B captors on d6 and now
Bishop to b4 and now nepo has a huge
threat of Queen captures on h6 as the
Jeep on is now pinned by the bishop as
well so there's a it's very hard to
defend this nice panel tries roof
six and now how do you continue this
attack never played Queen to f4 and it's
a really really strong move it threatens
Queen to f5 and then Queen to h7 will be
a huge threat if you want to prevent any
ideas here you will have to further
weaken your King side just not something
you want to do so here Necip a no played
Queen to d8 now hoping that if if Queen
to five then he can trade down into this
worse endgame after rook to e1 check
rook captures Sonny one na comes at
Bishop captures on f5 now comes Bishop
captures in g7 are very important in
between move as you want to capture the
Queen with check because if you just if
you don't do this then after you trade
black will capture on d3 with checks so
you're not going to be able to snatch a
piece so here first you capture on g7
Bishop characters now you capture the
Queen with check rook captures and only
now do you capture on a5 so you get this
position where white is up pawn but you
know the bishop sort of opposite colors
black you know had some I had high hopes
of holding this position to a draw but
after Queen to e8 nipple did not play
Queen to a5 never played a different
move feel free to pause the video here
and try to find this killing killer idea
and move 19 which is just insane you
know a 19 move miniature in modern chess
it is just insane a while I give you a
couple of seconds of course for those of
you who were able to do it
congratulations you are in excellent
movers of rooks that were lifted and for
those who just won't enjoy the show rook
to e3 such a wonderful idea and it's
hard to imagine that such a move wins
the game because what's the point you
want to get rid of the rooks control of
the h6 square so of course it's you know
we don't even have to mention that if
rook captures then just Queen captures
on age sex with check you cannot capture
King g7 at King j18 0.87 is made so
capturing on e3 is not an option so what
are your options
well you can try to unpin you can play
King to g8 but now now you get the same
idea Queen f5 I'm going for Queen to h7
and after g6 now you play rook captures
on e6 Queen captures and now Queen back
to
three and blacks position will just fall
apart it seems like black has a lot of
options here but really whatever he does
let's say Bishop g7 you can just go rook
e1 kick the Queen away and after Queen
to d7 there is really no good way for
black to even continue playing you can't
develop the bishop you can go here
that's not even a move you can go here
the bishop is controlling the a6 squares
so whatever you do well after white
captures of course H capture send g6 you
can play Bishop captures and b4c
captures and now f5 is okay you do
control the f5 square but now just Queen
to h3 going after this pawn after the
King blocks now raakhi seven sorry not a
rookie seven right away but first of
course Queen to h4 going for rook the e7
check and well what do you do King
captures here ro rook to e7 and now
whatever you play the Queen is captured
you can just well not even that if you
play a Queen to d8 you don't even have
to win the Queen you can just deliver
mate just queen g4 as the pawn here is
pinned King to have six and now Queen to
g7 will be made so that's one of the
options you have after rook to e3 and
maybe another option would be Bishop to
d7 just trying to develop them but then
you run into rook captures and e6 Queen
captures and now rook to e1 again where
do you go with the Queen you have to
move the Queen out of control of the of
the h6 pawns or whatever you do just
wink after Sun h6 is coming or you give
up your Queen here but there is no
compensation for the Queen
it's just lost all of the threats are
still still here so after rook to e3
you could try f6 just numbing you know
the the influence of the bishop on d4
but again Queen to a5 just going after
age seven this is such a powerful idea
and black is you know full black skinks
that is full of holes
if King g8 then it's not a problem Queen
h7 check King here and I'll just Bishop
to g6 check wins the Queen it's it's all
over so after rook to e3 move nineteen
as I do say it leave you theater and I
see panel resigned
and an epic victory for young upon
machine run six of the Dortmund chests
meet up and it's really gentlemanly I
have from nice piano at resigner move
nineteen you know not trying to you know
play something like f6 you know waste of
humor moves just to make it seem like
the game lasted 25 moves this way
history will remember it as a 19 move
miniature and you know it's a you know
we should definitely congratulate both
players on on such a such a lovely game
yeah that's the game I do hope you
enjoyed it I would like to think I'll be
some pyro and Mario and see no sorrow
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon
continuing the coverage of defeating
Grand Prix we have to check out the
finals continue the Capablanca saga and
check up on your suggestions such you
know as this one and also do not forget
to update your agamotto chess walk thank
you I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day